let's Cass has been nominated for an
Emmy for her latest stand-up special
boyish Girl Interrupted
her Amazon series one Mississippi which
is loosely based on her life will be
available for streaming on September 9th
she and her wife recently welcomed twins
into the world and I was just told she's
bringing them out with her so please
welcome our good friend and her two kids
TIG Notaro
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay most people leave their children
backstage when they come on the show
this is Max and Finn I'm told
yes yeah why are they wearing these wigs
well my wife had to go to the grocery
store and our babysitter is very
controlling and I had shown pictures of
them on TV and she was like you have to
put them in see a wigs to protect their
anonymity is is to protect the anonymity
of your of your children is the sea of
wigs okay all right I take this wig off
no no no it's very clearly a him okay
has your comedy changed a lot since
you've had kids because I knew our new
obviously before you had kids but now
it's no I mean this is my babysitter's
calling hi see ya
how's that really see ya that's sorry I
just landed I'm ready to babysit very
excited okay well they're here with me
at Conan I think in a week's yeah
they're they're in their wigs well it's
getting late I guess they should
probably be getting to sleep right yeah
they're actually all riled up right now
well maybe this will it's better be good
bye baby
the bow breathe
hang down will come baby cradle thank
you I can't tell if they're asleep
because of the wigs yeah yeah actually
could somebody put them in my green room
yeah so they can FaceTime with SIA until
I'm ready okay well that was very nice
their babysitter you go thank you so
much okay you know you know who these
people are right no no all right
somebody to get them off my hands are
thank you today
I thank you too see ya that was here see
it's my babysitter see his your
babysitter yeah is our baby understand
she's never met the children really
she only face times only face times good
time yeah
you